because when you're yourself you're
probably a piece of [ __ ]
never think about that [ __ ] when when
you give people the advice just be
talking to you guys
[Music]
welcome back to another great episode of
careful boys we have with us Chris Sosa
I love being here all right let me ask
you a question do you think at any point
of your life you felt like you were
socially awkward
socially awkward yeah did you ever oh
man I didn't find out until I moved to
LA that I would be socially awkward when
it comes to like uh like what my first
time like being in the green room as a
comedian because it's like it's a lot of
pressure when you're when you're a new
comedian going to a green room uh um
you're in a room with other Comedians
and you have you feel like you have to
be funny you have to like damn you know
throw in the jokes you're trying to like
impress a little bit and network at the
same time Network and then you're also
there because just measuring dicks yep
you know with comedy though yeah uh that
funny bone funny dicks funny boners
exactly you would do really better than
Green Room
why you gotta make it so real why can't
we just shoot the [ __ ] as homies here
Why Can't This Be Like A JK News Talk
Show where we just he wasn't even like
yeah about me would that be good yeah
that would uh that would [ __ ] turn my
boner down dude that would annoy me I
would I would be I would get back in the
car and be like okay I was uh yeah it
was uh there was there was a couple of
those but yeah it was heavy like I like
in with that you know yeah do you feel
like you found a natural Groove with
that now or yeah yeah I found a natural
Groove uh because it really spoke for
itself when I get to Stage when I get to
stage and I would like I would get down
when I get off when you go into the gray
room it's like oh damn we're okay I see
so that made me feel comfortable with
like with other Comedians and all this
stuff it's kind of just like I would
just let my work show like what it is
like that's that's good yeah yeah yeah
and then that's what and then from there
like then I'm like because now like and
it feels so dope I really appreciate
comedians that I respect they respect me
and they give me props they give me love
they they acknowledge like yo we see the
growth we see what you're doing and you
know it's even even since I've been back
now you know like I would even say I got
way more comfortable with you guys you
know because I remember my first time
like a couple times I was like nervous I
I didn't know how to jump in y'all were
doing the JK thing when was that it was
like a long it was years ago right it
would have been like 2018. oh wow yeah
yeah it was a little bit ago oh a
pre-pandemic for sure oh uh uh I had
these I know [ __ ] shirts I was like I
was like I got you one I got you one
that was fun you wore one bro I thought
that was like so tight it was like the
next time that they brought me back he
came with it on and I was like oh hell
yeah so you know it's just I liked it
it's just funny it sure says I ain't no
[ __ ]
closet sweetheart yeah you consider it
[ __ ] I always wear your [ __ ]
Kinder shirts
[Music]
I can't be giving compliments out here
man no I'm very I'm very considerate
that's really good because uh I like
that it's tied in with you know the
confidence you have in your skill yeah
transfers into the conflict you have
socially like because I think a lot of
uh solutions for social awkwardness are
just like easier said than done you know
when people go dude be yourself
no one likes myself I don't like that
yeah because when you're yourself you're
probably a piece of [ __ ] never think
about that [ __ ] when you give people the
advice just be yourself talking to you
guys what if yourself was a horrible
human being he's talking to some of you
guys
because until you are even self-aware of
yourself you're a [ __ ] desperate ass
[ __ ] Sim thirsty [ __ ] you're
like oh you want me to be myself then
I'll be [ __ ] just creeping out the
[ __ ] bedroom window of the girl I
like what if yourself is You're a Mean
human being you don't even know that
you're mean and you go around being mean
to people and then people are mean back
to you and you're like I don't even know
why people are so mean to me and it's
like you just got what you dished out
and [ __ ] unself-aware [ __ ]
and I think the key is not being
yourself but try your best to be
self-aware what you're so so what people
do is they'll imagine a negative image
of themselves yeah and it's like not
realistic right it's more there's a
manifestation of fear yeah or they
imagine a positive image of themselves
and it's not realistic and it's not an
accurate portrayal of how people see you
and I think that's probably what you
want to achieve is as close to how
people kind of of see you yeah you try
to unravel all the things that you think
you are right I think be yourself only
applies to people that are like putting
on a front it's like you're not really
being yourself you're trying to impress
you're trying to do this or that but
that's not you're being the Creator the
character that you created exactly so
that's I think that's what they mean by
be your actual self not the one that
you're projecting yeah yeah versus like
be yourself but like naturally you're
like either a sociopath or like a
murderer it's not like that that's not a
good idea yeah I think Anthony you're a
good example of like front no no
he's a fake ass [ __ ] huh why you gotta
double down I already made the joke
self-deprecating
where's my I ain't no [ __ ] shirt man
give it to me I want to play just to be
honest my opinion of Anthony's like he's
he's really cool like in his reputation
that's why we gotta take him down like
[ __ ] cool guys so then
like going back in time to like even
like early college you wouldn't have
thought like you were the coolest dude
right you just were very uncool okay
there you go you felt uncool in college
I felt like uh no I felt very uncool in
high school yeah and then college and
and this is a crazy con this is a whole
other topic but I felt like college was
a chance to um
I feel like the transition I became very
self-aware and then therefore I started
putting energy into becoming the person
I wanted to that was your Reaper so like
I feel like yeah that was my Rebrand I
feel like there was an essence of like
fronting but fronting with purpose right
because if you don't like
almost manifest the energy and the
person you want to become you you won't
become that person you know what I'm
saying so I felt like I had a second
chance to be a better person than I was
in high school that's all I had the
opposite oh no good oh
um because you know how some people say
fake it till you make it or they're like
you just gotta be confident but in a lot
of times when you're working that stuff
out it comes out wrong like you're
egotistical you're not ready yet and
you're entitled because you're just you
think you're this person which I ran
into all of those things as well as well
yeah we all got to work through all of
that and then but you're right though
it's kind of like you have to have this
image of who you want to be and work
toward that but along that Journey
there's weird things that like we know
clearly if someone's fake like hey
you're just you're just a fraud you're
not who you think you are but then
what's the difference between that and
someone who's like working toward being
bad yeah okay I think I think that's
you're just really pushing your own
battery and just seeing where those
boundaries are at if you go too far
behind this line then now I'm
egotistical or if you go past this line
it's like oh people are working out yeah
yeah they're figuring out all right all
right I don't want to be that cocky you
know what I mean I just gonna let me
dial it back from there but you have to
get there first to understand yeah it's
always a double-edged story people be
more confident they go I'll be more
confident than you know you too cocky I
gotta tone it down but how did you find
your voice like how did you find your
stride having to meet like when you
enter college and you're meeting new
people every single day and you're
making well you you saw like every shade
of me I think and it took all four years
to like get to who you want to be no not
necessarily but I do think that like um
there's like your journey and then
there's also recognizing your journey uh
relative to human beings around you I
think I got very very either lucky or my
awareness wasn't just my self-awareness
but awareness of like peers that were
healthy for the person I wanted to
become you know what I mean so if I
surrounded myself around like better
people than the chances are they're
going to rub off on me and I'm gonna be
more like them you know what I mean I
was I was easy to uh adopt mentors and
be willing to like put myself into that
position be like hey you know like I
don't know that much if you could please
like you know I know you see something
in me if you don't mind just like did
anybody ever check you and go hey bro
you're being kind of weird just kick it
yeah I think I think all my friends
checked me in one way or another but
like I don't think I was like somebody
who needed to get Hella checked I just
think there are like enough people that
would be like anchors yeah hey you know
it's not like you're crazy it's just
more like hey uh we know what you're
trying to be or like you know what I
mean close friends are like we
understand who you are and like what you
want to be and stuff like that so
um just stay in the lane a little bit
better is all you know I had that uh in
high school I was like I was pretty
popular I was known for dancing uh
performing doing talent shows uh we'll
get boxing like and training and stuff
like that and then I joined theater and
then I was like I was booking every raw
audition for us I was really like I was
that guy and I and I and I I held that
too I was you know I got the uh the most
most likely to be famous award and
Senior year yeah and then uh most
talented is what the two that I won I
didn't get most funny I I was kind of
all I thought that's when I wanted right
but I got those two and I uh which
obviously it don't it don't matter but
it's one of those like all right cool
like I got those things but then when I
moved to LA I'm 19 I'm thinking I like I
was the [ __ ] right but when I moved out
here I found out that like everybody's
out here is the [ __ ] you know and and
they're and they're gold at what they do
like I remember when I went to like it
was it was a a a like a dance night
where all the dancers come out to this
spot the the federal upstairs oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and I was
like well I dance
this was actually the the night where I
got humbled like I actually got
discouraged from dancing because I was
like I remember like the Les Twins were
there uh um they're good one of the best
like uh like all these like casters
they're in the cipher they're just
they're going in and I'm and I'm having
I'm having my moment of like okay I'm
about to go in there right and I and I
went and I remember going in and
everybody obviously they've never seen
this face before but it's one of those
like like okay and then it was like
there all right and I wasn't really
doing cold moves I wasn't getting
reactions I'm like oh did you get did
you get like wait this works in Houston
yeah for real I was like
I was cool right I'm like trying to oh
oh dude it felt it felt so it was like
it was like I I just remember like they
loved this in Houston
oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] I still do that oh bro
that works everywhere still though I
left bro and I was just I was like damn
like I'm not as cold I'm not as I'm not
as the [ __ ] as I think I am you know and
I and I and it was like it was humbling
and I had to I stuck with just like
comedy and I'ma just stay in my comedy
Lane and learn the comedy stuff but
still figuring out those like being
self-aware yeah alert learning all these
things being uh nice because another
thing is like I was always like uh uh
afraid just kind of like I didn't want
to have problems with anybody I don't
have any issues I wanted to be accepted
so I was always so people pleaser
no for real oh yeah I would be like
exhausted but by the end of the night
like my cheeks hurt because I was just
so smiling so much and but it was all of
those learning things of like that how
to go is this two nice dial it back and
all these things and then it turned into
being self-aware of like okay yeah like
you know who you are know what's too
much I love to give props I love to give
credit when it's due and does it can
come off as like are you just like
you're just like thirsty are you sucking
up whatever but like no I I genuinely
mean it I'm gonna give you props I don't
need props back I'ma just give it to you
you know like that's just that's just
how I rock but I I know now of like
what's gonna be like oh you're just
you're just being that guy like bring it
back so I just give it to when it's due
that's all that's tired that personality
that you were like emulating of like
yeah that's like that's what I had like
as a as a young person like when I was
like 12 or 13. he used to be socially
awkward well yeah I used to just kind of
I just didn't know anything and I used
to be too much and I used to be too loud
and everything was just too high and
then my neighbor who is this Korean DJ
who was like super cool he was like two
years older than me one day I went over
to his house to just hang out and him
and his friends they were just like
smoking just very chill and I've never
hung out with anybody that had that Vibe
it was like I was just hanging out with
other kids and then this dude literally
said to me you ever do you know how to
chill
and I was like what do you mean what do
you mean
I was like aren't we chilling now you
know and it was that exact energy and he
goes he goes he goes check us out just
chill and just don't talk and just chill
I literally went
and he was such a great like just that
day that really stuck with me forever
because he was like you don't always got
to be saying something bro and I never
met anybody that had that mentality I
was like like 12 or something and then
the second time that it really
solidified it for me was during the era
where I already knew you and this is
kind of I don't think I've ever said
this but uh I definitely didn't tell
Cindy who I owe uh our mutual friend
Cindy Manoa she was like a a famous like
dancer in our scene she was in kava
modern and back when I was just a
spectator in all these different shows I
used to attend them and I'd never been
on that stage I used to watch people and
I was like dude this girl's dope I
thought she was so cool I had like a
weird crush on her
and then I would see her at parties
where you were also at and I wanted to
like you know talk to her but I was
still kind of too excited into him and
like I didn't know that people thought
that was annoying and then um I
remembered like a year later I didn't
see her anymore and then a year later I
was just like this one day I was at
another party there's I was just tired
and uh he's like yeah this guy's so cool
all right guys so cool man so exhausted
that I was just chilling and I was just
like like this for most of the party and
she came to you he came to me and she
literally just said you're pretty chill
oh [ __ ] that's a Ratatouille moment it's
like she goes back to chilling with this
homie and then we started like no we
didn't date or anything but like we we
became really good friends and then we
were talking and then she was like you
know I never really noticed you until
you were like more calm
and I was like dude you just saved my
[ __ ] life you know where I learned
that from the dog park
what socialized dogs right that's such a
Bart thing to say bro socialize dogs
they're literally like this
right and then you have another dog that
never really goes out
like that and then you know he just goes
up to every single dog once sniff their
ass sniff their ass and then this one
that's insecure is biting out of no
reason like that right and then even the
secure dog that's just chilling like I
come to the dog park all the time uh
aggressive dog could come up to that dog
and go like that and that guy's just
like
you know and you kind of just observe
seasoned just from like Natural Energy
you're like oh [ __ ] like when this
people are chilling you can tell who's a
chill one you can tell who never gets
let out you can tell the one that's like
this guy runs the show at the house and
you're just like what the [ __ ] and
they're like damn I think humans are
kind of similar you can kind of tell the
overhyped one or the guy that's like
Puffs his chest not at the bar but it's
really because he doesn't know how to
fight you know so he wants to over
compensate right right that's
interesting that you observed that
that's a key observation
you took a lesson they're like that's a
life lesson right there everybody's like
why is this guy look at that dog so long
everybody else is looking at the dogs
like stay away from that guy he's having
a [ __ ] breakthrough
that is something I wish
that is something I wish we were taught
is paying attention Inward and the
energy that we give and like but like
everyone's talking about Vibes now
whatever right but they never talked
about this [ __ ] but we were like in high
school or I mean no one would even
because our teachers weren't players
those were the and those were things
that you had to and you had to get from
a from an OG or a home yeah exactly who
would fly who was fresh but also the
lesson sticks more when you learn it
firsthand and not someone just telling
you oh this is how you should be this is
what you should oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it sticks more when it yeah one of
the biggest lessons I feel like the
biggest lessons you learn are like the
harshest ones and like I pride myself on
hygiene now uh but I remember the exact
moment like it was yesterday and I
remember going to my best friend's house
and after been playing in the summer
right and I go and play at his and where
uh he got these new turntables so he's
like I'll come over check it out I'll
hell yeah we walked to like Thrifty's
Ice Cream we got ice cream all that's
just like a hot day I go inside his room
and he goes bro you smell like a dog
and then from that point I was like I
was socializing with dogs
I was like what the [ __ ] does that even
mean so I was like
and then I was just like I was just kind
of like all in my head now and I'm like
dude is my mom buying the wrong
detergent or like because I take showers
every day and I'm like what the [ __ ] and
then so from that point on I think my
whole like smell good regimen I had to
make sure that I nailed it like you know
I'm like dude my mom I'm like I'm gonna
start doing my own laundry mom because I
don't know what the [ __ ] you're putting
in these clothes I gotta start buying
[ __ ] name brand [ __ ] I'm like what
kind of shampoo you guys use okay like
herbal lessons I'm gonna buy some name
brand [ __ ] can't be buying some [ __ ]
Chinese shampoo whatever the [ __ ] she's
using at home you don't have to switch
the whole thing up I think all because
of that one moment that my homie caught
me
yeah I feel like uh when you're hanging
out with people and somebody smells is
it like wrong to like call them out or
is it it's wrong to call them out in
front of everybody else because then
you're like also being like hella whack
but if you if you have that relationship
and you pull them to the side at the end
of the night or some [ __ ] and you're
just like I gotta keep real with you man
you kind of smell funky yeah because
that could like save their life like
socializing with other people because
that might happen if they some people
stubborn dog we tell people and then
they just like no and multiple times
yeah
think when people have like kicking
breath or like you know things that they
can't help too it's like for example
like super sweaty Palms that like any
time that I shake your hands their hands
are sweaty it's like if you're close I'm
gonna be like hey do this whenever you
shake your shake hands like wipe your
hands before you [ __ ] shave people's
hands yeah man because it's not the
Judgment of who you are as a human being
but it's an experience with another
human being that you're gonna have so oh
yeah you just feel like you gotta be
around homies that are like like if
somebody's got [ __ ] something stuck
in there yeah you got [ __ ] in your teeth
we're gonna take a [ __ ] picture yeah
right you know what I mean like you say
it because like that's just like you
also want to be around that if there's
something wrong with you like even in
the crew like we have something called
swag check you'll just say it out before
the show or or before performance or
like before you're about to get on stage
or the camera's about to roll it's just
like hey yo swag check and then
everybody just has to check one two
everybody and make sure you're all
honest and then give them a kiss on the
cheek right yeah because you don't want
you want to let your boy [ __ ] to not
look good either and you know like one
sleeve is like inside out or something
yeah you shoot like sometimes your zip
your [ __ ] flies down you know what I
mean that's dope that's dope because
most guys are too busy doing nut checks
Bangkok boom and they're like what the
[ __ ] we're about to go on the stage the
Dance World the dance world has really
uh helped me with that like big like my
I gotta give you shout out to my cousin
yo be easy when I moved back to Houston
it was that like he was he's old he's
always fly he's always fresh he's always
smooth and and it goes It goes with his
style of dancing too he's an all-around
all-style he's a b-boy but he can get
down whatever house a popping lock like
he can get down
um but it was one of those like I would
I was always going to his crib and like
I would have my fit you know and and
every now and then he'll be like he'll
just toss me a Jaguar rock this you know
and I'm like oh you know and he'll and
and then and then he ended up telling me
like bro like you know we're we're
family bro like we look good okay we're
good looking people so there's not a lot
of people who are out there that look
good so we have to own that and keep it
up cool he was like he was old he was
always just like yo like keep your keep
your you want to be puppy puppy fail you
know
so he was keeping it you know keeping a
g with me and so um I was and and I
always appreciate that because it gave
me so I feel like even though I'm an
adult now I'm still getting gems and it
was like the perfect gems to like feel
confident of knowing the room that I'm
like I'm flying I'm cool I'm like we
would always have these like yo just Let
It Rock or like oh it just happens like
this is like the stuff like that and
then and then going to like a uh uh like
thrifting like that was this thing like
let's go thrift and he'll he'll find
some little like some some sneaky some
gems and like you know it was just like
I really appreciate that and it gave me
it gave me like the confidence to like
when I came back out here I knew that
like I'm going out there Papi Chulo
yeah man that's that's easy good
guidance yeah hell yeah everybody needs
that everybody needs a big brother or
sister that just keeps it real where
it's not about like liking you today but
it's about loving you enough to say [ __ ]
that like you know isn't necessarily
friendly but you need that I have that
but as my wife and I'm Gonna Leave My
Eyes goes is that how you want to Brand
yourself off all right I'll go back here
and [ __ ] go changed it God damn